dos polos opuestos se disputan la
presidencia de perú las diferencias
llegan a tal punto que desde que se
conocen los dos candidatos
presidenciales grupos de peruanos
marcharon en contra de cada uno de ellos
al maestro castillo lo llaman terrorista
chavista y comunista consideran sus
ideas de izquierda radical una amenaza
democrática tenemos un totalitarismo
venezuela
[Música]
terrorismo nunca más dice ayer vencimos
el terrorismo este 6 de junio tenemos el
cerdo nuevamente sin embargo figuras
políticas creen que se trata de
estigmatización mediática precisamente
para beneficiar a su contrincante keiko
fujimori el 22 de mayo una unión de
sindicalistas activistas y estudiantes
organizó una marcha multitudinaria no a
favor de castillo pero sí en contra de
keiko fujimori por representar la
herencia de su padre a quien se reafirme
en insultar si es elegida
le vamos a permitir no le vamos a
permitir a la señora primaria
asesinado
ha violado derechos humanos
ha estado involucrado por el
narcotráfico y no lo pueden venir a
decir ahora la señora que es una
demócrata no lo vemos un cambio
democrático que no implique corrupción
y una magia llamada fútbol la familia
fujimori no es el país el país es esto
debemos elegir con memoria debemos
elegir de manera valiente debemos optar
por una opción de cambio y no porque
unos pretenden hacer retroceder 2030 a
la dictadura
a una semana de las elecciones la
polarización se refleja en un empate
técnico según una encuesta de datum y en
casi un 20% de indecisión